do you notice a big difference between
like female athletes and male athletes
like okay because fighting is a pretty I
don't wanna say exaggerated but it's an
interesting thing where you know you
have men and women kind of differently
but doing the same thing if you will
yeah
um do you notice a difference in their
mentality
well they vary so much individually
that's what's interesting it's like
you'll find even male fighters or like
super laid back and then you find other
ones that are really intense and super
emotional and it's really hard to tell
like there's a there's Gunnar Nelson is
a guy from Iceland you know is I know
yeah fantastic jujitsu guy you cannot
get that guy to change his expression it
doesn't change you could punch him kick
him in the balls
he stays stoic it's a weird he's a weird
guy yeah he's very on one side of it and
then there's like guys like Conor
McGregor who's also his training partner
who's on a completely different side of
it he's screaming and yelling and
talking to everybody and you know
that's that's part of his flair right
you know they vary so widely and it's
that's true with girls too some girls
are brash and outrageous and they get in
other girls faces and put their knuckles
on their nose and they're at the
staredown and other girls bow and they
hug and they take selfies together it's
like everyone has their own sort of
approach to it yeah it's very
interesting it is interesting I'm always
I'm I'm in fighting and intrigues me and
that I think it's interesting that
you're trying to be offensive and
defensive at the same time dealing with
fear like all these things happening
simultaneously and I then take it I look
at it one step further with a female
because I don't know I I I'm interested
to know how if a female can fight from a
not not a non-emotional place but
without her emotion mm-hmm like just
like okay I'm in my male I'm in my
athlete and I'm not gonna be like oh she
didn't just kick me in the ear you know
I'm like freaked out you know what I
mean myself you know like I've only been
in one fight my whole life and the girl
hit me in the face and when I saw my
blood I was like oh no she
did not just hit me in the face you know
and then went crazy but if these girls
could be like because they're so well
trained as an athlete how that can
supersede like or override actually like
this in that feminine impulse of like
you know reaction a reaction that's a
masculine impulse to though I think it's
a human impulse if a guy punches you in
the face you get furious it's so hard
for people to not get emotional when
they get hit yeah because you want to
get it back that's a good point
it's a very bad way to react in a fight
to fight with emotions because you
expose yourself right you leave yourself
open for counters you just you miss your
rhythm you're not as deceptive and your
emotions
you're too obvious in your pattern and
so many times you you get hit a lot more
it's a it's a big problem with fighters
that that emotion is a very big problem
and the wanting to break people like
letting them hit you so you could show
them that they can hurt you can take
risk Yulin thing too stupid it's very
stupid take it on the face on purpose
and then just like come on come on come
on that's what you have yeah then that's
a terrible emotion though you can get
completely knocked unconscious doing
that happens all the time it's just the
smart thing to do is to fight with
correct technique and with a correct
strategy meaning you have an
understanding of how to execute best
it's not just waited and let bombs fly
it's you have to you have to be very
precise in your tactics you got to be
very smart I think it's interesting
though those sports where there is that
I mean listen versions of it is football
you know living with Laird obviously you
know he always says he appreciates
mother nature because it's like you make
good decisions every more did you make
bad decisions you you pay a price but I
think it is very interesting when you
have two humans
strategically trying to deconstruct one
another hmm the chess the physical chess
that goes on as like looking at it from
another athlete spointer222 put
themselves in that situation yeah you
know it's like
I understand almost like you know a
surfer and a wave and a rock climber in
a mountain I get that like I'm gonna be
a part of that but I find it really
interesting and even sort of I'm even
more curious about women like who say
like yeah this is gonna be my sport they
vary so wildly like there's Holly Holm
who's oh she just seems like awfully
sweet she's so she seemed like she'd
bring you cupcakes come I'll show murder
you
I mean listen I saw that kick but then
it's like I'm so sorry I made you these
after you know right cookies it's like
okay I'll get it
you know when I cook from the hospital I
don't know it's it is interesting when
you see girls like that yeah well
they're all different I always want to
know do they have brothers mmm like
where they rabble-rousing and that their
whole time and it wasn't and they
learned to play and it wasn't personal
you know and like a little contact was
okay